Here's a real example of a poly
alphabetic substitution cipher.
It is called the Vigenere cipher.
Vigenere cipher has a clever way
of representing possible mappings
from one letter to another as a matrix.
Here we encrypt the plaintext by
processing one letter at a time
across the columns.
We use the letters in a key to tell
us which row to look at the mapping.
Now suppose we have a plain text, and
the first three letters are A-T-T,
and we have a key.
In effect, the key stream should
be as long as the plaintext.
So this will be lemon,
lemon, lemon, and go on.
Here, the first three letters
of the key stream are L-E-M.
Now let's see how we can encrypt
the plaintext according to the key.
We encrypt the plaintext by
processing the letters one at a time
across the columns.
The first letter is A,
so we look at column A.
We use the letter in the key, L to look
at the row to decide the mapping of A.
Here the mapping says L, which means
in server text, A has been mapped to L.
The next plaintext letter is T.
So we look at column T and
we use the letter in the key to look
at the row to decide the mapping.
The letter is E in the key.
And so we look at column T and row E.
And the mapping is X.
This means that the cipher
text of T is X.
The next plaintext letter is T again.
So look at column T again, but
here the letter in the key is M,
so we look at column M, and
the mapping of column T, row M, is F.
This means that the cipher text of
plain text T is F, therefore for
plain text A-T-T and key L-E-M,
the corresponding cipher text is L-X-F.